c'est simple c'est depuis la
restructuration
la plupart des employés sont paniqués à
l'idée d'être licencié plus personne ne
délègue donc on essaie de justifier son
poste ils ont peur moi je crois que j'en
suis dit les conséquences faites
attention continue et c'est très bien
est-ce que c'est aussi le cas des robes
tout petit peu déconcertant oublier
caméra titouan que c'est pas des caméras
fois pratique et c'est un cerneau
thiérache sûr on visionnera ensemble tu
pourras t'améliorer moi aussi on va tous
les de s'améliorer continu continu
serait améliorée oui intérieur
jamais compris sa première étape de
l'entretien d'évaluation
écoutez le collaborateur sur sa réalité
quotidienne le laisser s'exprimer fut
sincèrement sur le sujet pour instaurer
un climat de confiance je t'écoute
notre société a connu une
restructuration non il faut que tu me
regardes moi oui là c'est parce que je
fais des apparts et occupa t'occupe pas
tout ce que tu as à faire c'est me
regardez moi d'accord chimiquement mois
capitaux donc je disais à cause de la
restructuration avoir pelleté pu tuer la
restructuration s'était pas vissé tu me
disais c'est pas évident pas évident non
c'est depuis la fusion que clairement je
n'ai plus de deux missions sais rien je
tourne en rond voilà il te souviens de
106 comme un sentiment de lassitude
clairement déçu dit extrêmement stable
je sais pas ce que c'est si c'est toi la
lumière le cadre mais c'est nul à gg pas
l'émotion je sais pas tu es ce que tu as
décroché un moment donné c'est pas
inintéressant crochet de toi voilà j'ai
parlé des lycées je pars en train de
jouer là non je sais bien que je vais me
dit lassitude extrême à 200 si tu me dis
la cité l'extrême bronze mais là c'est
ce que je te dis je dois transmettre il
imagine toi tu ne dors plus la nuit les
jeunes ont promis s'ils écoutent et quel
connard j'ai pas blessée humiliée comme
ça elle est répartie répartie tout de
suite la répartir et partick ne sentez
pas avant que tu arrives là ça va vous
faites quoi bon film je filme
l'entretien d'évaluation à super super
idée et a besoin et tout jeune expliqué
que j'ai l'impression que je ne sers à
rien ouais ben je sais ça j'ai lu un
article là dessus dit s'ils sont assez
fous je crois que c'est une personne sur
trois qui a un emploi que sert à rien 3
4 qui va mal ça va pas passer la lumière
allez-vous attentes
ça montre la confiance monte maintenant
puis au vote des relais sont un petit
peu la top super tu mais attention mais
non rentables ou faisaient bouger ni
quel super parfaite fazila oui je je
disais que je me retrouve à un moment de
ma vie mais en fait crac qui va pas on
n'a pas créée ni aux semences a fait
promet attaché en juillet-août
non pas qu'on est bien mais seulement
s'ils touchent autant sinon c'est pas ta
si on sent qu'elle avait de l'eau ça m'a
fait mal être aref salem 6 mai limoges
toit après maître augustin
c'est parti je me suis fait mal mais ça
sentira temps c'est ça la grille
d'évaluation tu utilises dénoncé la
méthode comme j'en peux plus en fait je
entendu rivés sur youtube essentielle à
33 keitel et beaucoup d autres tu la
connais la 33 critères et bien sûr mais
elle est beaucoup plus à l'écouté
collaborer les chiffres on leur fait
dire ce qu'on veut je sais toi qui dis
ce que tu veux
brasser plupart et ils ont ces rebelles
et ce pourquoi on n'irait pas au quai
deuxième partie de l'évaluation
le collaborateur et le drh comparé leur
grille d'évaluation chacun de leur côté
pour ma part j'utilise ma propre grille
et que j'ai adapté avec des nouvelles
catégories et un code couleur c'est le
meilleur outil aller à les actions c'est
la bonne mais moi d'un plan
social qui va travailler voix sur elia
attendez quoi que tu te soutient bon là
là ne t'inquiète pas on ne va pas te
licencie newey
non non
mais c'est vraiment pas ton salaire qui
fument